are going to go straight to Molly's  family let's have a listen her father  Ian as we've been hearing has been  pivotal in the fight for justice in the  last um we've heard much about one  tragic story  Molly's story  sadly there are too many others  similarly affected right now  at this point  I just want to say however dark it seems  there is always hope  and if you're struggling please speak to  someone you trust  or one of the many wonderful support  organizations rather than engage with  content online that may be harmful  please do what you can to live long and  stay strong  I'll give a fuller statement  soon at the church Hall when I've had  some time to collect my thoughts and  I'll be joined by others who would like  to say more about Online safety  but for now  I'd like to thank you all for your  support in reporting this story so  sensitively  and I hope that this will be an  important step  in bringing about much needed change  thank you